we lifted this result we've been doing
things by first principles so far right
but we noticed when you do things by
first principles you start to notice
some patterns and math notes is all
about patterns right I in fact one of
the first derivatives that we looked at
this guy actually may have been the
first one right we saw okay you take
this and you get 2x if you would a
different shape if you were
differentiating find the green function
of X cubed you again 3x squared and if
you did it with X to the 4 you get X
cubed right so we thought surely surely
is going to be a pattern here right if I
differentiate to take X to the 400
please don't make me do that by binomial
with first principles right good morning
I should be able to take advantage of
something so we went back to first
principles and we developed this rule to
say if you have extra power any power
any number then you're going to get this
one um I guess what you'd say is that
power it comes down out the front become
becomes the coefficient and then you
drop down the power by 1 and then voila
all of your results right so we've been
going through this feeling quickly let's
just come back to this for a second and
just make sure we surround this with the
right language because I've been saying
a few things so if you've met this
language before some of you have it
ok so first this guy at the front I
think I alluded to it but just to make
it really cool this thing is called the
differential operator the differential
operator just like laws or sign or
functions like that which requires some
input right so you can't say for example
log base 2 equals 5 right because this
log P is an operator it's but you
operate on something right so you've got
to have something in it just as much as
you've got to have you know like 3 x
equals 18
be something therefore to operate on so
if the differential operator right what
this specific different differential
operator means is this one is
differentiate and because there is an X
down the bottom here and it so it's D on
DMS right it means differentiate with
respect to as if the variable you should
be looking at and a play this kind of
rule to the variable you're after is X
okay now differentiate with respect to X
this with respect to comes up so often
you'll often see it abbreviated as W R T
with respect to and you'll need to catch
a little bit you can see I could apply
this same process to anything like with
a different set of letters it's just a
label it's just a label right so you
might see for instance D on DT right
differentiate with respect to T and that
often is like times so if you have
something like T okay you'll beat that
soon enough you can differentiate with
respect to any variable variable for
example you could differentiate with
respect to R right now
this this let's just think about this
right just imagine it today just imagine
right so what you're going to do is
gonna pull that power out the front
that's - there's a pie just hanging out
there it's just another number and then
you're going to breathe up our down by 1
right so it was 2 before should L be 1
and that should make you really really
suspicious we'll come back to that
result in time so this is a differential
operator because they're next down there
it means differentiate with respect to X
and because it's an operator there has
to be something in here ok there has to
be something so this is your function
right this is the function
being differentiate
anybody
once you differentiate it right excuse
me
what'd you get over here this result
this is called our derivative I've
thrown this word in there before the
derivative it just means it literally
means you know it comes from something
else right it came from this original
function you differentiate it and then
you end up with the derivative we
introduce this idea as it gives you the
gradient right so it's also called the
gradient function they're just different
names for the same thing okay the
gradient function if you have some point
like x equals 1 and you want to know
what is the gradient of this at its all
because what you put x equals 1 into the
gradient function very very important
this is differentiating powers of X ok
so this process the differential using
the differential operator and getting
the derivative even though it's called
the derivative this is not this is not I
will throw that influence actually if
you say this process is deriving it's
not deriving it's differentiating and
that's why the title is what it is and
why if you ever he'll be talking about
trying to tell the difference between do
things I always say distinguish not
differentiate between those two things
because in my head
that's what differentiating is okay so
these are all other words you'll hear me
use them interchangeably here find the
derivative of this let's find the
gradient function let's evaluate the
gradient and such as such a point this
is not we're afraid to okay so that's
what we looked at last time let's now
think about this there are a lot of
things you can extend this issue's okay
you can extend this to regular old
ordinary powers okay but what about for
instance if I differentiate a number
like 3 or 4 or 5 or 600 right I'm just
going to class their ball as C as in
constant numbers so if C is just some
real number okay what all the different
the derivative
all of this real number B yeah it's it's
just gonna be zero now you can see this
from two different points of view okay
firstly you can see it is the fact that
a constant is really a power of X in
disguise is it not okay so it's it's X
to the zero right so it kind of what you
have X to the zero X sorry constant time
is X to the 0 ok what happens to that
zero well it's going to first thing come
out the front so B 0 X to that and then
it doesn't actually matter what I do off
that because I'm multiplying by zero
right so therefore that just disappears
it's just going to be zero there's
another way you can see this do a really
really quick sketch for me underneath it
because we are doing more than just
algebra right just apply algorithms to
this we're trying to work out the
gradient of this thing well what does a
function look like
if it's just equal to a constant right
if I have say like you know f of X or Y
equals 5 what does that look like what
kind of graph is it described y equals 5
it says to me like it's a horizontal
line right I mean that's the name else
what I was gonna say next
say you've got some kind of horizontal
line in now the gradient on a horizontal
line graininess rise over run how much
is this thing rising it's ah it's not
rising at all
okay it has a great all 0 okay so we get
this result by applying our rule with
the dolphin fish principles but also for
just thinking about what is this
actually doing it's fighting the grade
of a horizontal line which is zero